- On this episode I film the show
right before I take the
stage at Good Day New York.
(upbeat hip hop music)
♫ 'ey, Gary Vee!
♫ You ask questions
♫ And I answer them
♫ This is the #AskGaryVee Show.
- Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 119
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
Um, we are in some sort of room here.
I'm about to go on Good
Day New York, co-hosting.
Guys, you know, let's
talk about the people
that have crossed over,
you know, Michael Strahan,
Mario Lopez, you know, listen,
also I think when you
really think about it
anybody that's co-hosted
or hosted morning shows
has really come from somewhere else,
and so maybe this is a preview to me
one day being the host
of Good Morning America!
I don't think so, but I'm excited about it
my mom's more excited about it,
so from 9 to 10am today in New York City
tri-state area on Fox 5 I will
be the co-host of the show.
I'm gonna do a little segment
on wine, so that should be fun
a little throw-back Monday for me.
Big shout out to the entire Vayner Nation,
I really appreciate the tremendous words
and kind remarks from episode 118,
a little impromptu, we
decided to play basketball.
India texted me and
said she got choked up,
many of you did, I really appreciate that.
So with that, India, DRock
you're gonna have to move.
- You messed it up.
- Let's get into-
- The show. Damnit!
- The show!
(both laugh)
That was a good one, I kinda set you up.
People that watch it backwards will see
I set you up for it, I made
a movement and it caught you.
Let's get right into it, because
I've gotta get on the air.
- [Voiceover] Galen asks,
"How would you market
"to Amish people if that
was your primary market?
"#BuggyHustle."
- Galen, this is a tremendous question,
and I think it opens up
an opportunity for me
to give a broad answer.
The truth is, I'd probably
spend six months to a year
before I would say a word or market,
for me personally, because I completely
am undereducated on that market.
I don't know what makes that market tick,
what do they, you know, obviously,
what, if anything, are they buying?
You know, obviously I'm
not deeply knowledgeable.
Obviously I have headlines on what I think
is going on there, preconceived notions,
but I've learned in my 40 years of life
those tend to lead you to disaster
when you're making
assumptions on the market
when you don't intimately know it.
You know, for me, the two core businesses
I've run in my career, the wine business
and an agency that markets
within social media,
if you pay attention
closely, they were markets
that I spent five to seven, eight years
being deeply in before I took the reins.
One, obviously, in a family
business growing up in it,
and two, really participating in it,
being a thought leader
within it, jamming with it,
using it, and I mean, I
was using social media
hardcore for, you know, five, six years
before I started VaynerMedia
to then give advice around it,
and so that's what I would
do, and that's what I think
a lot of you are making huge mistakes on.
Interacting with so many
of you on Instagram,
Facebook, Twitter, I notice this quick,
you know, I wanna sell sneakers, right?
I wanna be in the sneaker game,
and yeah, you kinda like sneakers,
but do you understand
the sneaker business?
And I went with the huge pause there,
Staphon, for a specific reason:
When you decide to jump into business,
yeah, you may like wine, but do you
understand the wine business?
Yeah, you may have a Twitter account,
but do you understand
social media business?
Yeah, you may have some kicks
and have six or seven pairs
or even 50, but do you
understand the sneaker business?
And so if I'm marketing, I'm in business,
and if I don't understand the market,
if I don't deeply understand
the competitive landscape,
the supply and demand chain,
what I'm gonna do, the
marketing opportunities,
the white space that I
love to play in so much,
then I'm gonna lose, and
that's why so many people lose.
They confuse enthusiasm or hobby
for business skills, and
so before you do anything,
before you jump into anything,
I highly recommend, you know
so many of you are starting
T-shirt companies without
doing a hardcore audit
of the 50 hundred T-shirt
companies in the market,
and what they're doing and
how much they're spending.
Do your damn homework.
- [Voiceover] Daniel asks,
I've started a startup
that many others have tried
to do before me &amp; failed.
Am I stupid to think
that I'll be the anomaly?
- Daniel, that's a tough question,
because the truth is,
there are some mountains
that are very difficult to climb
and thesis's that people
love to think are real,
and they're never able to
really fully get there.
I think the anonymous social network space
is gonna end up being one of them,
I think that brings
out the worst in people
and ultimately kills
itself from within itself.
That's one preview to a space
that I'm not bullish on,
that I think a lot of people are gonna try
to climb that mountain, that said,
it just takes one tweak, one turn.
You know, there was a lot of industries
where people couldn't
figure out how to win,
and then eventually somebody
came along and won that game,
and so I think that very
similar to the first answer
in this episode, it
comes down to your chops,
your skills, your patience,
your infrastructure,
and really really really does
come down to your skill set.
I really do believe that, you know,
anybody can do anything
if they're good enough,
if they're the first of that thing.
I just think that people
have to be very realistic
to also understand how special
and rare that actually is.
- [Voiceover] Nathan
asks, "I'm in the middle
"of transitioning to a new job.
"I was wondering what your advice would be
"for my last two weeks?"
- Nathan, I'm gonna give
you some really good advice
that I think a lot of
people here need to hear
as you transition from job to job.
I actually think the last
two weeks of your job
are one of the most interesting times
you can have in your career.
It's something that I've
spent a lot of time on,
paying attention to the behavior
of people that have spent
last two weeks at Wine
Library or VaynerMedia.
I think that your actions
in those two weeks
will really be much more impactful
on your future career
than you may realize.
I think the grace and being
the bigger man or woman,
and humility, and all the
things that come along with it,
are all those great traits
that I like to talk about
pretty often, are so imperative
in those last two weeks,
because everybody's watching.
Your coworkers are watching,
and definitely your employer is watching.
It's stunning to me how many people
have come back around at a
year later at VaynerMedia,
asking me for help, asking for a job back,
when they were actually
terrible, or not terrible,
that's not fair 'cause
I'm very competitive.
You know, they were, oh I'm
going to this great gig,
and like trying to impact other people
to make them realize how they're going
to this amazing place, and it's funny
how the grass is not as green
once you land on your new location,
and then when you're lucky enough to work
for somebody who's a good
guy and that has some power
and then you go ask for
something, all you had to do
was be the bigger woman
for those two weeks
and I would go out of my way to help you.
I think way too many people
burn bridges on the way out,
bridges that they need,
because the shortsighted nature
of our society, much of the
themes of the 200 episodes,
or 150 episodes, or 120 episodes.
Lou, how are you my man?
Come give this man a little bit of daps
on the #AskGaryVee show,
I know he watches it.
How are you? Thanks for having me on.
- I've been jabbin' away on social media
saying local TV will never be the same.
- I love it, I'm excited.
Let me finish this show,
I'll be with you in a second.
I think burning those
bridges is a devastating play
that way too many people feel,
out of excitement sometimes, or out of,
you know, cynicism and
all the negative things
that then kinda makes
me feel that it's fair
that they're unable to
mend those relationships
and get value out of
those past relationships.
To me, there's no value in anything
other than being over the top awesome,
giving love to everybody,
making amends with people
maybe that you didn't work
well with, the last two weeks.
I think you treat it like the last month
of high school, senior year, right?
You just make it all good.
- [Voiceover] Nils asks,
"If you were to make
"a video game, what type would it be
"and on what platform
would you sell it?"
- Nils, this is a pretty
interesting question.
There's two spaces that
I think video games
are really interesting, and
one is obviously mobile.
I still think mobile,
kind of word, simple,
like, the game that
works for the 13 year old
and for the 84 year old grandmother
are always super interesting to me,
very basic, you know, just simple word,
brain quizzes, you know, Hangman 3.0,
that kinda stuff is super interesting.
But the place that I'd probably go
since I love so much the game of following
where I think the puck is going to be,
is I'd probably make a
virtual reality game,
one that had, you know,
kind of like the Zelda of VR,
which was a completely open world
where you could do a whole lot of stuff.
I don't know if I would go shooter,
though I think that's gonna
be the breakout win early on,
I'm a little bit more into like,
Gauntlet really affected me
in the early days, it
was like one of the first
four player arcade games
that me and my boys
back in '84 would roll into Chuck E Cheese
with quarters for days
and just get down with it.
And I was always pumped to
be the princess, by the way,
everybody would fight for the wizard,
I'm like I'll be princess, she was nasty.
Anyway, so I would say
some sorta open-ended
Zelda-Gauntlet adventure type game,
for virtual reality, that
I don't think would pop
for another 24 to 36 months,
but if you follow the
narrative of my 20 year career
and hopefully what I do
for the next 40 years,
I'm always going to bet on where I think
the market's gonna be
24, 36 months from now
use my disproportional ability to sell,
to keep me afloat for
those 24 to 36 months,
and then be there where the
market's gonna be there.
When I started selling social
media to brands in 2009,
they didn't wanna buy it.
Only now, only as we
head into 2016 budgets,
am I starting to see some real upside.
And as you can imagine, that
bodes well for my business.
I would do the same thing
in the video game industry.
- [Staphon] The stream
just shut down.
- Why? Just crashed on you? Cool.
- [India] So, Britt.
- Hey Gary, this is Britt Michaelian,
and my question for you
for the #AskGaryVee Show is,
what women in business do you think
are just rockin' it on social media?
I love to follow people
who are doin' great stuff
and I'd love to know who you think
is doing an exceptional
job on social media.
Women in business, thank
you, have a great day.
- Women in business, social media.
This is tough for me
for a couple of reasons.
One, I really don't follow anybody.
You know, all I'm really doing
is putting out content and
engaging with my own audience
and so I'm not trying
to duck the question,
obviously there's plenty
of people that pop to mind
that I think are incredible
entrepreneurs and business women
you know, Katia, CEO of
Birchbox, an investment of mine.
Obviously since I'm an investor in it,
I'm a little bit closer to it.
I think she's an incredible
operator and entrepreneur,
Rachel from MikMak, another investment
that I've made that I'm in love with.
Brit, Brit Morin's probably crushing it.
Britt Dako, another investment of mine.
These are businesses that
I'm closer to, you know,
Spoon University, Gals,
either, they're crushing it.
Again, I have no clue what
they're doing on social,
I know what they're doing in marketing,
in operating, in
leadership, in being a CEO.
I assume Brit is doing a great job
'cause her brand is at the forefront,
and I have seen stuff in the past,
but I've been very head
down for the last 24 months
really on this show,
and running VaynerMedia,
and obviously the
Vayner/RSE capital venture stuff,
so I've been a little
busy, though the truth is,
and I'm just gonna let it out of the bag,
I've never really followed anybody
because I just don't have the time for it
and I'm really gonna
only do my thing anyway,
which could be a weakness, by the way.
I don't think this is some
great, oh I'm so cool,
some amazing strength that
I don't follow anybody else.
It's just how I roll,
and as I always say here,
you need to do you.
So, I apologize that I don't have
a great answer to that question.
Savvy Auntie historically
has done an amazing job
I'm a big fan.
So, those are some of the answers.
Tight show, very focused,
I think what you're seeing in my demeanor
is I'm starting to get
mentally prepared for The Show
that I'm gonna be doing.
Not "the show" but the
show I'm doing today.
Question of the day,
what female entrepreneur
is killing it on social media?
If I can't answer it, you guys will.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
Oh yeah, one last thing
from today's episode.
Next Friday, not this Friday, yes,
next friday the 31st, I'm going to be
flying in three of you to take over
DRock, Staphon, Steve,
Unwin, that's Stunwin,
India, all of their jobs,
for the one year anniversary
of the #AskGaryVee show.
I'm picking three super fans.
Fill out the form,
they're all handling that,
we'll get you more info on that.
DRock, maybe take over the thing,
I don't know what you're gonna do.
But, bottom line is, three of you
are coming next Friday to
take over the crew's job,
hang out with us, we have a meeting,
it's gonna be a full #AskGaryVee
experience for three of you.
I hope you win, I hope you get picked.
Good luck!
So if you're available fill out the form
and I'll see you in
eight, what is it, seven?
Like, 11 days?
(mumbles)
Whatever, I'll see you soon!
(everyone laughs)
(upbeat hip hop music)